la defensa del expresidente Pedro
Castillo ha presentado un recurso de
habeas Corpus que hace unas horas acabas
de ser admitida trámite Por la justicia
peruana en la acción legal se pide la
liberación inmediata del ex gobernante
hay que señalar que se trata de un
segundo recurso de habeas Corpus porque
hace unos días atrás los abogados de
Castillo presentaron un primer recurso
de habeas Corpus que fue rechazado por
una corte Pues bien en esta segunda
acción legal se pide que se libere Pedro
castillo y se señala que el ex
gobernante fue detenido de manera
irregular e ilegal por el delito de
rebelión y se especifica que no existen
pruebas que señalen que Pedro Castillo
se habría alzado en armas y habría hecho
uso de la violencia para cambiar la
forma de gobierno del Perú si este
segunda acción legal de los abogados de
Castillo no consigue éxito Ellos tienen
previsto presentar una nueva demanda
ante Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos porque consideran que se estaría
vulnerando el derecho a la libertad de
Pedro Castillo así como su derecho a
seguir ejerciendo el cargo de presidente
de los peruanos ahora crecen las
protestas Francis en las calles de Perú
por la crisis política y el bloqueo de
carreteras además contanos en esta línea
A qué medidas está tomando las
autoridades
precisamente la policía peruana ha
suspendido las vacaciones y los permisos
del personal ya encendido la alerta ante
el aumento de las manifestaciones y las
marchas de protesta que se realizan en
todo el país exigiendo la renuncia de la
presidenta Dina boluarte el cierre del
Congreso y la convocatoria de nuevas
elecciones paralelamente a eso también
se ha ordenado aumentar las medidas de
seguridad en los alrededores de la base
policial de Heroes donde el expresidente
Pedro Castillo viene cumpliendo
detención preliminar por siete días y
también se ha ordenado mejorar el
control y aumentar la seguridad en los
alrededores del Palacio de Gobierno
donde hoy se espera que al mediodía la
presidenta Dina boluarte tome juramento
a su primer gabinete de ministros